in this video i'm going to be breaking
down the second episode
of attack on titan season 4. unlike the
first episode
this one was less focused on action and
it was more about the characters
strategizing what they need to do next
so in this video i'll explain everything
that i thought was interesting
including zeke's plan falco's feelings
and a bunch of other stuff that you
might have missed
be sure to hit that sub button if you
want to see more attack on titan videos
like this
and of course let me know what you
thought of the episode down below
okay so episode two was called midnight
train and it starts off with the mali
generals
discussing the aftermath of the war we
saw last week
i know some people were really confused
about what that war was about
so to summarize it quickly the battle in
the last episode was the culmination of
a four-year war
that the nation of mali was involved in
mali is where characters like zeke and
reiner are from
and this four-year war started because
other nations thought that mali was
vulnerable
after losing the colossal titan and the
female titan
that's why in the first episode zeke
said it was their failure that caused
the war to happen in the first place
coming back to episode 2 the mali
generals have begun to realize
that technology is beginning to surpass
the power of the titans
i mean we saw it even though they won
the war the anti-titan weaponry that
their enemies have developed
is a sign that titans won't be enough to
win future wars
all this talking culminated in maz
mickelson realizing
that other nations are surpassing mali
when it comes to technology
and something needs to be done this is
where zeke's plan comes in
because he believes that if they were to
invade paradise island again
and reclaim all the titans then this
would give marley enough time to safely
develop technology that would you know
bring them back up to speed with the
other nations
as the beast titan zeke only has one
year left to live due to the curse of
ymir
and so he wants to invade the island as
soon as possible
zeke's successor is colt grice and if
everything goes to plan
then he will be the one to inherit the
beast titan in a year's time
moving on episode 2 gives us a look into
reiner's mindset
as he is still traumatized from the
events that happened on the island
he's grilled by porco galliard who is
the new draw titan
and i did a video about poco's backstory
if you're interested
poco believes that ryan never should
have been sent to the island in the
first place
and he just absolutely roasts him for
all his failures
including the fact that pogo's brother
died to save reiner whilst they were on
the island
later in the episode we get another look
at the four new warrior candidates
and one of these guys will be the next
person to inherit the armored titan
reiner later admits in the episode that
gabby is the one who will most likely
get it
but in truth falco wants the armor titan
just as badly
for reasons we'll get to in a minute an
interesting thing to note about this
episode
is that with the titans becoming less
useful in war
this means that the usefulness of the
aldean race has
also decreased as we found out in season
3
eldians are the only type of human that
can transform into a titan
and because of this they suffer from
racism all over the world
tamale the main usefulness of eldians is
that they can become
titan shifters but as one of the warrior
candidates mentioned
what will happen to them once the titans
are obsolete
it's possible that eldians could be
exterminated or maybe treated even worse
than they currently are
anyway moving back to the reason that
falco wants to inherit the armored titan
he revealed in this episode that he
essentially wants to get it
so that he can save gabby's life if gabi
was to get the armored titan
then she'd be guaranteed to die within
13 years due to the curse of ymir
not to mention the fact that she'd
probably die even sooner than that
because anti-titan technology keeps
improving because falco clearly has a
crush on her
he wants her to live and reina tells him
that if he wants to inherit the armor
then his only option is to surpass gabby
and become
a better warrior than she is as the
episode progresses
the train takes the aldians back to
liberio which is the hometown that
reiner kept referring to during the
earlier seasons
liberia is a malian city which has a
segregated area for aldeans to live
which is just further evidence of the
discrimination that they face
in liberio eldians have to wear armbands
to signify their status
warrior candidates like falco have
yellow armbands and titan shifters such
as reiner
wear red armbands including their family
as well these red armbands give them
pretty high status when it comes to
aldians
but they still have to live inside the
segregated zone
as falco is on his way home he notices a
bunch of eldian soldiers on their way
to be treated at the hospital we saw in
episode 1 how eldians during war
are basically expected to give their
lives for no reason
and commander mcgath was originally
going to sacrifice 800 aldeans
before gabby decided to step in with her
plan which is why everyone was praising
her during the episode
anyway falco notices how one of the
aldian soldiers
has his armband on his right arm which
is not something a person from liberia
would normally do
because it's always meant to be on the
left falco helps this person put the
armband on the other side
and tells the man that he doesn't need
to fight any longer this man has very
interesting features
but i will leave that to your
imagination this moment was then
followed by
family dinner in the brawn household and
i should probably mention that gabby and
reina are cousins which is why they're
having dinner together
what was interesting about this scene
was the difference in mentality
between rhino and the rest of his family
as someone who's actually been to the
island
reiner knows in his heart that eldians
on the island are just like normal
people
whereas gabby and his mother and the
rest of his family
they're convinced that the island must
be full of devils that need to be
exterminated
reiner himself used to believe this but
now that he knows the truth about the
island
everything's kind of changed and gabby
is beginning to notice the difference
in rhino's personality episode 2 ends
with the warriors of mali having a
meeting
and the anime left out this wonderful
scene of pete crawling on all fours
which i will personally never forgive
them for as the cart titan she stays on
all fours for long periods of time
so it's just started to feel more
natural for her to be in this position
which is why she was lying down during
the meeting and why she had a crutch at
the beginning of the episode
zeke explains to the warriors that when
technology you know when it's
finally a hundred percent surpass the
titans then eldians are finished
he explains his plan to invade the
island and retake the founding titan
which will give mali enough time to
rebuild their military
however even if the plan is successful
it won't actually do anything to stop
aliens being persecuted this is when
zeke unveils an additional plan to save
the eldian race
which requires the help of the tiber
family the type of family are the
holders of the warhammer titan
which is the only titan not yet seen in
the anime they are the most respected
aldeans on the planet
as their ancestors are widely known to
have fought against the aldian royal
family
during the great titan war the great
titan war is what resulted
in mali gaining the power of virtually
every titan shifter
except obviously the founding titan and
the attack titan not only are the tibers
incredibly wealthy
but they don't interfere with the lives
of regular ldm people
this is why eldians live in the
segregated zones as the tigers just
choose not to get involved
zeke announces that the tigers are
finally ready to help out
and will use their position to remind
the world of the threat the island poses
and in doing so they will kind of like
make it seem
that mali will invade the island very
soon this strategy is designed to show
the world
that the good elden warriors are going
to stop the bad eldians who live on the
island
which will hopefully go a long way to
stopping discrimination against their
kind
as this meeting took place mali and
generals were secretly listening in the
other room
to see if all the warriors were showing
any signs of dissent
zeke subtly warned the group that they
were being listened to but it seems that
rhino was the only one who noticed
and that's why during the episode reiner
interrupted porco
because he didn't want poker to say
anything that was incriminating
but anyway guys that was the breakdown
for episode 2 of attack on titan season
4.
i'd appreciate if you dropped a like if
you liked it and be sure to check out
this other video i did
which imagined which my hero academia
characters would inherit the nine titan
shifters
until the next one peace out